we got another new pokemon sun and moon
trailer because hey it's tuesday and we
learned some pretty cool stuff I'm Tony
and this is your revolve gamespot news
update the highlights of the trailer are
the evolved forms of the new starters
rowlett becomes the wise looking dar
tricks litton becomes the sly toric at
andpop Leo becomes the graceful Brione
the trailer also showed off the new
festival Plaza in this social space you
can complete tasks and earn coins for
spending at the plaza shops finally we
learned that a special demo was coming
to the eShop on October 18th this demo
contains a unique greninja that
transforms into ash greninja previously
seen in the Pokemon TV series ash
greninja can then be transferred into
the full game speaking of Pokemon Sun
and Moon releases on November eighteenth
at this rate we'll see even more
trailers and new pokemon x launch day so
keep an eye on gamespot for more and for
all the biggest pokemon news you're
already in the right place
you